amia is the line designed by Alexander
matushi a Frenchman Paris to be exact
he's got a beard a red cap a unibrow
he's always surrounded by his cool
friends in case you didn't take French
class that's exactly what a me stands
for friend there's a place for cooky
conceptual fashion and this is not it
these are tailored clothes for the
street wear generation just be so play
on shelves in the coke in one gun show
kids Ephesian up up up in chocolate
jeans denim jackets a sports jacket the
tracksuit what makes it fashion lots of
references from American culture street
culture active wear jackets 80s American
Gigolo striped tank tops from surf
cultures got baseball jackets he's got
stance and style sneakers it's like
Americana personified I've seen some
greaser references with the wife-beater
and the open shirt each individual piece
is something you want to wear right and
he likes that right I can buy that track
jacket mix it with you Levi's denim
jacket guys when it comes to style if
it's been through a French prison it's
probably gonna be even cooler I think
it's as simple as that right that's very
well well one thing I wanted to just
point out is this amazing blue suit and
it's a really hard blue to duplicate it
sounded Italian blue is not American
blue it's a French blue I love it
because it has vibrancy you can tell
that the fabrics a little bit thicker
which we talked about before and then
he'll put a pair of white sneakers with
it which has a very American profile to
it here he's just doing this big shaker
knit sweater you can't find this
somewhere else it's just a black sweater
there was this great quote from Alex he
said I just want to make a really nice
sweater why does it need to be zippers
all right
here you have it I remember not liking
acid wash the first time around
somehow I feel the second time around
it'll be palatable especially the way
it's worn so this is his nod to normcore
the good the bad and the ugly of
American style yeah yeah it's like a
challenge as a designer if you can make
acid wash look cool then you've really
got exactly got the touch with the track
jacket ingredient green what Alex did is
he actually layered some of these pieces
so this is an homage to French tailoring
which is a very hard good high armhole
to build up shoulder
and then he's completely thrown it off
with the track jacket pair of white
sneakers which makes it completely young
and has nothing to do with Wall Street
number two - is the suede baseball
jacket American bomber nice shape to
that chestnut color I can't argue with
you on that one mr. Moore that's that's
really a baby it's so cool that has a
little bit of sophistication to it
because of the color I'm gonna take it
in I know
number three the Glen plaid sport jacket
this is silk and wool look at the end is
beautifully unlined you're just gonna
want to like put your hands in your
pockets and flip the collar up and be
really slouched you wrote with a t-shirt
or sweatshirt and travel with you it's
just it's already got that patina to it
that incredibly vibrant geometric
graphic sweater these colors are so user
friendly you could put this with
anything from the acid wash to the track
pan - pair of khakis or just apparently
advice the next few years every time you
reach for this you're gonna remember
where you were when your bought it we're
gonna remember this season it's gonna be
awesome to put it back on that's what
those like statement graphics do that's
four you got one more I'm loving
crunches this spring and I really love
this one I don't know if it's because
I'm tall and I know this one's gonna fit
me it almost looks like for me it came
from like the costume warehouse at a
film studio or something like I got worn
once on set a neck preserved in the
salts of time I think when we step back
and look at these five pieces it's like
they say so much with so little that's
really could be a foundation of a spring
wardrobe right and then it's very easy
to build on that with you know some
simple pants and shirts and pair of
jeans and obviously a pair of these cool
on these sneakers you and I are going to
go through all of the major collections
keep watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel and they will just come to you
you don't even have to find them they
will find you to get an inside look at
some of the other fashion collections
come back and subscribe to the GQ
YouTube channel because we do this stuff
a lot because it's dope because it's
cool because there are videos